اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بلدات
عده بالضفه الغربيه وقد تركزت الاقتحامات
في بلدات يعبد جنوب مدينه جنين ورامين شرق
مدينه تكرم وديا غرب محافظه سلفيت كما
دهمت قوات الاحتلال منازل عده واعتدت
بالضرب على شبان ما ادى لاندلاع اشتباكات
مع مقاومين قاموا خلالها بالقاء عبوات
الناسفه تجاه جنود واليه
الاحتلال هذا وقال مراسلنا ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتقلت ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في مدينه حلحول شمال الخليل
بالضفه واضاف المراسل ان قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت منازل عده وفتشتها والحقت ضررا
باحدى المركبات قبل الانسحاب من
المدينه في جنين اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال
عددا من قاده حركتي حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
في بلده عرابه جنوب غرب المدينه وياتي هذا
بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال البلده حيث دامت
منازل وفتشتها وعبثت
بمحتوياتها المزيد معنا من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري ومن الخليل مراسلنا
منتصر نصار ارحب بكم البدايه معك محمد وهل
من جديد
اذا نعم سفيان عمليات اقتحام اسرائيليه
واسعه تتعرض لها مدن وقرى ومخيمات الضفه
الغربيه في هذه الاثناء وتتركز هذه
الاقتحام خاصه في مدن شمالي الضفه الغربيه
تدور اشتباكات عنيفه في مدينه طول كرم
شمال الضفه الغربيه في هذه الاثناء بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت المدينه من محاور
عده وسيرت الياتها في عدد من الاحياء
وحاصرت بنايات سكنيه ودهمت عددا من منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين تسمع من احياء طول
كرم اصوات تبادل اطلاق النار في هذه ايه
الاثناء وفي وقت سابق كانت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قد اقتحمت بلده رامين ايضا في
طول كرم وهناك سيرت قوات الاحتلال الياتها
العسكريه وجنودها المشاه في احياء هذه
القريه ودهمت عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين واطلقت قنابل الغاز وقنابل
الصوت باتجاه المنازل وايضا هناك اعتقلت
او اوقفت عشرات الشبان الفلسطينيين وفتشت
ودققت في هوياتهم الشخصيه وحققت معهم بشكل
ميداني فيما تشهد ايضا مدينه جنين شمالي
الضفه الغربيه ايضا ايه عمليه اقتحام
اسرائيليه واسعه في قريه يعبد على وجه
الخصوص التي اقتحمتها اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه وسيرت هذه الاليات في شوارع
البلده واقتحمت عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وفي بلده عرابه ايضا في جنين
اقتحمتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ودهمت
منازل الفلسطينيين واعتقلت عددا من قيادات
حركتي حماس والجهاد الاسلامي في هذه
البلده فيما ايضا تشهد مدينه نابلس وخاصه
قريه بيت فوريك غربي المدينه عمليه اقتحام
واسعه من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي ايضا سيرت دورياتها في احياء هذه
البلده وجنودها ايضا ودهمت عددا من منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين وكذلك تشهد مدينه
طوباس اشتباكات بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومقاومين الفلسطينيين بعدما
اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه كبيره هذه المدينه
وسيرت الياتها في شوارعها وحاصرت عددا من
البنايات السكنيه في داخل طوباس فيما تشهد
ايضا مدينه قلقيليه شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وا اقتحاما من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتركزت هذه الاقت التحامات
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في حي كفر
سابه داخل مدينه قلقيليه وهناك تحاصر
القوات الاسرائيليه في هذه الاثناء عددا
من البنايات وتقوم ب مداهمه منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين وتفتيش
هذه المنازل بشكل واسع في
هذه الاثناء فيما كانت ايضا قوات الاحتلال
قد اقتحمت قريه بديا في فيم الفيت ايضا
وسيرت دورياتها في عدد من احياء هذه
المدينه ودهمت منازل مواطنين فلسطينيين
ايضا ابقى معنا نذهب الى منتصر اذا اعتقال
ثلاثه فلسطينيين شمال الخليل ومداهم
لمنازل ايضا ماذا في
التفاصيل نعم سفيان الحال لا يختلف كثيرا
في جنوب الضفه الغربيه عما كان يتحدث به
الزميل محمد عن وسطها وشمالها في جنوب
الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في الخليل قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت
مدينه حلحول شمال الخليل واعتقلت ثلاثه
فلسطينيين هم اسرى محررين واعتقلت مواطن
ونجله ايضا خلال اقتحام المدينه وتفتيش
منازل المواطنين كما الحقت الضرر ايضا
باحد مركبات المواطنين خلال عمليه
الاقتحام وخلال عمليه الانسحاب اندلعت
مواجهات طفيفه ما بين الشبان وقوات
الاحتلال القى خلالها الشبان الحجاره
باتجاه قوات الاحتلال التي ردت باطلاق
قنابل الصوت وقنابل الغاز السام المسيلي
الدموع في هذه الاثناء قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم بلده بتمر شمال الخليل وتداهم عدد
من منازل المواطنين وتقوم بتفتيشها كما
ايضا شهدت منطقه دوار بيت عنون شمال
الخليل استنفارا كبيرا من قبل قوات
الاحتلال هذه الليله بعدما القى شبان
فلسطينين اكواع متفجره باتجاه النقطه
العسكريه المقامه عند منطقه دوار بيت عنون
قوات الاحتلال تواجدت بشكل كثيف وكبير في
المكان واجرت بحثا تمشيط واسعا وقامت
بالبحث والتفتيش في كاميرات المراقبه
المحيطه والقريبه من المكان تزامن هذا مع
ايضا قيام مستوطنين بالاعتداء على مواطنين
في خربه سوسيا في مسافر يطه جنوب الخليل
احد المواطنين كان في طريق العوده الى
منزله هذه الليله قام باعتراضه احد
المستوطنين اشهر السلاح بوجهه هذا المواطن
كان برفقه عائلته في هذه المركبه اشهر
السلاح بوجه هذا المواطن وهددهم باطلاق
النار وا امرهم بمغ درت هذه الخربه خربه
سوسيا والعوده الى مساكنهم في مدينه يطا
جنوب الخليل طبعا سوسيا تتعرض بشكل كبير
جدا مؤخرا الى اعتداءات مستمره ومتواصله
من قبل المستوطنين الذين يعتدون على
المواطنين ويمنعونهم من الوصول الى
اراضيهم وزراعتها ويمنعون رعاه الاغنام
ايضا من رعي اغنامهم في وقت تسمح فيه قوات
الاحتلال للمستوطنين برعي الاغنام في تلك
المناطق مناطق مسافر يطه جنوب الخليل شهد
هذا اليوم ايضا اعتداء داء اخر الخليل
شهده اعداء اخر من قبل المستوطنين في
منطقه حاره الجعبري تحديدا المستوطنون
وقوات الاحتلال داهموا المنطقه وقاموا
بثقب واعطا اطارات مركبات لمواطنين وتكسير
هذه المركبات والاعتداء على السكان في تلك
المنطقه التي تشهد ايضا اعتداءات مستمره
من قبل المستوطنين هذهه المنطقه التي تقع
بشكل ملاصق تماما ل مستوطنه كارات اربع
الواقعه في الخليل والتي يعرف عن
مستوطنيها بانهم الاكثر غلاتا وتطر
المنطقه سفيان منتصر نصار مراسل الجزيره
من الخليل شكرا لك وشكر موصول لمحمد خيري
مراسلنا في رام
الله